hello everybody today we have a great
day we're gonna have an exciting day I'm
gonna talk about position now that's
exciting
as exciting as it gets in physics
position
what is position or as some people call
it location others call it place
questions whether we're all talking
about the same thing well let's find out
today how do we do it in rational
physics well we start by defining our
words we have to have well-defined words
so that we can communicate property the
person can understand what you're saying
okay
and what is a definition some people say
well what's the definition of a
definition yeah we have that as well we
have to do that because we had all these
people asking questions it's a
limitation placed on the extent or usage
of a word put a limitation now you can
use it consistently hopefully right
rationally scientifically ok first word
you got to define aside from definition
is the word object because you can't do
physics without an object and we define
it as that which has shape okay so
what's the subject today we're going to
talk about position location place
whichever right and so where do we start
we start at the word distance okay so we
have to define what distance is it's
crucial okay and distance is simply the
separation between two objects as I like
to say distance is what lies between
lengths a length is the continuous
matter that you have between two
surfaces of an object okay and this this
is what separates two objects straight
forward okay what's location well
location is the set of distances you
have separation from one object to
another and one object has separation
from every object in the universe you
can take
when Adam and say well this Adam has
separation from every object in the unit
right every atom in the universe and so
that's the location of that object
because we don't look at we don't unroll
measuring tapes in physics
that's mathematics okay mother nature
deals with qualitative stuff she just
knows for sure how this that there's
separation between the earth and the
moon and between Jupiter in the moon and
she knows that Jupiter's a little
farther away than the Earth from the
moon
they have different separations that's
it she doesn't go in there with a
measuring rod and say let's see how far
away it is exactly no she doesn't care
about that yeah she's only qualitative
and that's what physics is about you
have to explain mechanisms and for that
we do not need numbers and a lot of
people have problems with that because
no one has ever dealt with physics in
the way we deal with it here yeah okay
so that's location from there we move on
to exist why because physics is the
science of existence and object requires
a location in order to exist if God
wants to exist he's got to have distance
with respect to the objects that are out
there
the remaining objects that exist okay
and that's it
very simple very straightforward we're
done you know as far as location is
concerned just a set of distances now
those are not the notions you'll find
out there from mathematics and where did
the mathematicians get their cues or
whether they start where they get all
their notions today that they have today
they got them sensing from Aristotle
that was the starting point maybe there
was someone before then very surety but
we have a book called physics written by
Aristotle where he kind of synthesized
either the notions that the Greeks had
in general or his own notions whichever
we don't care but the point is that's
the starting point for
or at least Western civilization that's
where mathematics grew okay mathematical
physics so-called science okay so what
the good old air you have to say about
position let's start at the beginning he
synthesizes this by the way his notions
in his book three of physics okay and
here it is okay this is our starting
point and he says the physicists must
have a knowledge of place as well as of
the infinite why don't know about the
infinite but place if I think I know but
he's going to talk about sounds about
right yeah we need to know what location
is people in mathematics they call it
position but they're referring to
someone else as will something else as
we'll see you today okay whether there
is such a thing yes plays the manner of
its existence place exists okay that's
what he's going to talk about and what
it is okay if it's a what okay because
all suppose that things which exists are
somewhere I love that he said it but he
didn't know what he said and anyone who
read Aristotle and read that statement
has no idea what he said or how
important it is let me read it again
because it's ultra important because all
suppose that things which exists are
somewhere the non-existent is nowhere
well he said almost perfectly but he
never realized how important it was and
nobody ever paid attention to that
statement yeah exist means an object
that has location and if it doesn't have
location it doesn't exist and that's
very important because you know you have
a theists and agnostics and theists
talking in circles and they never
defined or understood the definition of
the word exists and there you have it if
they would have read that statement and
understood what it how important it was
they would have saved themselves
hundreds of years of debate acrimonious
debate okay and because motion in its
most general and primary sense is a
change of place
which we call local locomotion change of
place I got a problem with that already
because change is already motion and
motion is change you can't have change
without motion you can't have motion
without change so they're synonyms as
far as we're concerned there is no
difference between change in motion and
you can't use the a synonym that you
find a word so that shows again how
important definitions are in fact his
definition is still what everybody uses
out there they see how it's has change
in place and location or whatever
no no changes already motion we say it's
two or more locations that's what motion
is that's definite saying it's a change
in place because again if you say change
in place are we saying that with change
the object move from one place to
another or was it the place that moved
okay maybe it's the place that moves who
knows okay but Airy
immediately starts with a disclaimer
that's quite interesting I had the read
that's because I I thought it was
interesting says the question what is
place presents many difficulties an
examination of all the relevant facts
seemed to lead to divergent conclusions
uh-huh so everybody's got a different
opinion what they think this place is
right moreover I like this part we have
inherited nothing from previous thinkers
whether in the way of a statement of
difficulties or of a solution yeah I
hear you were Airy I've inherited
absolutely nothing in at least in terms
of definitions from from the previous
generations nothing no one has ever
defined words no one and scientifically
right and you know it's funny because
who is it
Isaac Newton he said he stood on the
shoulders of giants well he was lucky I
stood on the shoulders of dwarves mental
doors okay no one defined any term
that's important to physics in the last
10,000 years
so it's not like I reinvented the wheel
it's that the wheel was never invented I
had to invent the wheel I had to
construct it nail by nail okay so what
is place let's see if we can get to the
bottom of it with mr. Aristotle here he
says he says the typical local motions
of the elementary natural bodies namely
fire earth
remember they believed in all this stuff
that there were only four elements earth
were in and fire and and then the fifth
element their quintessential okay fire
earth and watering and the light show
not only that place is something uh-huh
he same place is something of course he
never defined what something is he's
saying but say split that place is
something that's interesting because I
would say place is not something I think
it's more like nothing the opposite of
something but let's continue but also
that it exerts a certain influence so
here he's saying that not only it's
something but it bounces against the
something to her has some influence some
interaction with something this is these
are the notions he had okay this is made
plain also by the object studied by
mathematics okay and he says though they
have no real place at least yet ground
is that they nevertheless in respect of
their position relatively to us have a
right and a left do they you know I just
had a fellow who wondered about the
number line and you know you wonder
about that here here I have the number
line you say well yeah it looks like
it's got the Russian it's got a little
arrow there at the end you know in
Janeiro
so I call them and so looks like the
number line has direction right but
actually you know this is you know
numbers have no direction you know
number is is just a number you're
counting that's what number is okay and
here we have the definition again we
work off with definitions and number
it's just uh the verb to count it's not
a noun it's a verb
you can't picture you can't make a
drawing you can't make an image of the
word number yeah you can put a five you
can put a six but not that I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
number the word number you can't
illustrate it because the word number is
not a an object you can't point to the
word number two to whatever number
represents okay because it's a concept
and it's a verb to count what is it the
number of times that you move your
finger up and down okay it's uh as I say
they're naming each shake of the hand so
you go wand and you say to you say
string you give them names to every time
you shake your your finger
that's what number is and they made a
big monster out of out of number right
because today they have all these
notions that they've developed in
mathematics and all they had to do is
figure out what a number is and then and
all that is is just counting the verb to
count okay let's see if I had it here
yeah there was one more issue there the
theory that the void exists he's talking
about the void existing he says it's got
a he said exists what was exists exists
it has to have location if it doesn't
have location it doesn't exist he's
saying that the void exists the void has
place as he called it okay whatever
place is so far we still don't know but
that's important none of that he stated
that because he's saying the void is not
only a thing but it exists very
interesting involves the existence of
place for one would define void as place
bereft of body you get rid of the body
what's left that's place that was his
notion okay and yeah here we have he
continues he says these considerations
then would lead us to suppose that
places some
this thing from bodies yeah that every
sensible body is in place in other words
you have a place and you have a body and
the body occupies but he calls what he's
gonna call her it's gonna be analyzing
here what he calls place okay it has
three dimensions place has three
dimensions because you know you can't
have two dimensions or none no damage
you have to have some kind of dimensions
in that hole so that a body can occupy
it this is the sense he has okay length
breadth and depth again breadth and
depth are vectors they have nothing to
do with length and length has nothing to
do with these vectors length is a
dimension it should be paired against
width and height okay those are the
three dimensions breadth and depth and
elevation they're vectors okay that
dimensions by which all but all body
also is bounded okay but the place
cannot be body for if it were there
would be two bodies in the same place
that's his reasoning he's saying place
is not body because you would have two
bodies in the same place and he's saying
that that can't be another body occupies
the place when the first body leaves
that's his notion of what place is
that's that's the notion he's gonna use
so we still don't know what place is but
he's already telling you not only what
he thinks it is he's giving you some
hints so that you can look at that and
say ok I see where he's going with this
right and ok so here he he gives you the
notion of sense she's saying look you
have a thing in this case a box cube
whatever and you pull it out once you
leave behind is this place and place is
not the same thing as space because
place is a three-dimensional whatever
that the body beams behind when it when
it leaves and so it's like leaving a
hole in space okay that's that's his
notion of this keep that in mind that's
that's what he that's where he's headed
okay same place is something a
standalone thingy whatever that thing is
okay and
anything is to this day we we still have
these notions this a lot of these
notions okay okay so he tries to
summarize it here he says there are four
things of which place must be one okay
what is the shape the matter some sort
of extension between the bounding
surfaces of the containing body okay
or this boundary itself if it contains
no extension over and above the bulk of
the body which comes to be in it okay so
he says this for a place has to be one
of these four things and it's got to be
one of them and then he rejects three of
them here it is put it on the side so
you can compare them next to each other
form is the boundary of the thing the
place is the boundary of the body which
it printed which contains it so he's
gonna reject the first one shape okay
matter is neither separable from the
thing nor contains it whereas place has
both characteristics
that's his reasoning for rejecting
matter and the last one there if
extension were such as to exist
independently and be permanent there
would be an infinity of places in the
same thing that's how he rejects
extension and so he goes with this
reasoning one step further and says okay
what's left okay essentially that's his
reasoning here let me get this one out
of the way yeah and so he says he says
the party says if places none of these
of the three neither the form nor the
matter nor an extension place
necessarily is the one of the four which
is left namely the boundary so it's the
outline the perimeter anyway you want to
look at that of the containing body at
which it is in contact with the
contained body okay so he's saying
essentially it's gonna be the perimeter
the the boundary the outer surface you
could say any of those words would fit
in there just fine that's his notion of
it okay does he give us a
well now that's that's his notion that's
it that's as far as he goes as far as a
definition okay but then he adds the
following he says what then after all
this place okay what is it dear arey
could you please tell us the answer to
this question may be elucidated as
follows he says places what contains
that of which it is the place okay place
contains the something that's in in the
place okay contains it essentially place
is no part of the thing two separate
things a thing and the place right the
immediate place of a thing is neither
less nor greater than the thing okay so
it's the same size I guess that's what
you say place can be left behind by the
thing and is separable so yeah you know
you take the box you leave a hole so
places the hole not the box okay two
different things all place admits of the
distinction of up and down and each of
the bodies is naturally carried to its
appropriate place and rests there yeah
and this makes the place either up or
down okay
so he's got a another one I just didn't
put it in there because it was not very
relevant at all and so again I'm looking
for a definition and I'm not gonna get
anything beyond boundary okay because
what he goes Nash he says place will be
explained in this way he's gonna explain
what place is instead of defining it he
gives you already the notion boundary
and you get oh that's your your best
definition gay or what he's saying but
here he says there is no necessity that
the place should grow with the body in
it okay so they both have the same size
momentarily at least well the bodies in
that place north at a point should have
a place a point I thought a point was
zero dimension well what kind of point
has a place okay but whatever we have
four-dimensional space-time an event
what is that a point in space-time okay
so that's there you see where this comes
from nor that two bodies should be in
the same place okay so two bodies can't
be at least they understood that you
know you got to take one body up before
no
one occupies it when he's talking about
this he's reverting a lot to air and
water
keep that in mind he's saying you know
when water moves out air fills that same
space that same hole so Aristotle did
not believe in nothing he said there is
no such thing as nothing because as soon
as a body moves something takes its
place yeah that that place thingy that
that shape that's all it's got it's that
outer boundary that perimeter okay
no that place should be corporeal a
corporeal interval so it's devoid of
matter it's the void of a body yeah
that's what he's saying for what is
between the boundaries of the place is
anybody which may chance to be there not
an interval in body dang so he's saying
that you know you don't have nothing
nuts in there there's no interval
I guess so they also had this notion
it's not apparent but it's implied I
guess that all bodies were kind of made
of a single piece because if he's gonna
talk about there not being an interval
what is he talking about he's saying
there's no little holes in this object
that's all made of matter there's no
holes in this like a single piece you
know you would think that that's going
through his mind if he's gonna say this
make that statement there okay place is
also somewhere okay I thought place was
somewhere but he's saying here we have a
place that is somewhere okay not in the
sense of being in a place okay hopefully
right but as the limit is in the limited
some fancy wording there okay the limit
is in the limited okay what I remember
that each kind of body should be carried
to its own place okay the area to the
place four bodies which are United do
not affect each other
well those which are in contact interact
with each other on each other okay are
you saying that there
yeah what is it
United if they're united I guess they
don't affect each other because you know
they're one essentially I guess he's
saying there's no separation between
them who knows what he added mine there
but the point here is is the notion of
place place he says it's a boundary
opinion you might say well what is the
relevance of this today well yeah we
have we have seen because if it place is
a little boundary that's devoid of an
object that occupies that if there's
such a thing as place all by itself
stand alone you know what he's talking
about he's talking about a hole in space
and you know we've got that notion today
it's known as a black hole you know and
here you see an ocean you know uh that's
supposedly space and the stars and
everything and you have a black hole in
there except that this is a
misrepresentation of a black hole okay
it's a misrepresentation because you
know that hole as far as I can tell I
don't know if you would reach a
different conclusion but it looks like
it's a at least two dimensional it's got
a diameter it's got a radius it's got
size it's got everything of an object
which is essentially what Aristotle said
you know he says what is a place a place
is that which has this boundary or this
shape the outer shape right but it's a
devoid of an object and that's what a
black hole is it's something supposedly
right
it's got size and it's within space
which is something else yeah but in fact
they they made a picture of that you
know they claim that that's a black hole
gay in space and again you can see it's
two-dimensional at least for sure it's
three-dimensional gay but what is uh the
problem with that well the
is that black holes are zero-dimensional
they have no sighs there is no diameter
no radius in a black hole so we've got a
zero dimensional hole in nothing in
space here you have a mr. Stephen
Hawking he puts in his book it brief
history of time which was a big
bestseller a big seller and he says this
in think it's Chapter six
Chandrasekhar he was an Indian fellow
who came to study and work in England
right in the early part of the 20th
century and won the Nobel Prize
eventually so has calculated that a cold
star of more than about one and a half
times the mass of the Sun would not be
able to support itself against its own
gravity Chandrasekhar limit that's what
he calls it or that's what's known as
today Eddington he was a supervisor at
Chandrasekhar supervisor refused to
believe chandrasekar's result Eddington
thought it it was simply not possible
that a star could collapse to a point
meaning nothing zero dimensional we're
not talking about point being located
with two coordinates or three or four no
we're talking about a three-dimensional
object a star a you know a Sun
collapsing until it disappears
completely matter wise you know crushes
all matter out of existing it has no
structure that's what he's talking about
and he just in case in case you missed
it he says Einstein himself wrote a
paper in which he claimed that stars
would not shrink to zero size no doubt
about it they're talking about zero size
zero' volume zero
Dyanne or 0 radians the whole worth
nothing there except mass yeah it's a
pinpoint mass yeah if you want to think
of it that way what he was awarded the
Nobel Prize in 1980 it was for his early
work on the limiting mass of cold stars
Chandrasekhar had shown that the
exclusion principle could not halt the
collapse of a star more massive than the
Chandrasekhar Lake
yeah a black hole is zero-dimensional
and not everybody is aware of that in
fact uh I was on jf G's got hippies show
in Canada a couple times and I told him
this and he said well no it's not true
they don't believe them he believed that
the mathematicians don't believe that
it's zero got mentioned and here at
Chandrasekhar won the Nobel Prize for it
if people would read some of these
things they would not talk nonsense they
would say they would realize that what
the mathematicians are saying and that's
that a black hole has no size there's
nothing there except mass a concept wait
it's like they got rid of the elephant
then and what's left is is five six tons
whatever that's what a black hole is
that's what these people believe in and
that's what they say you know move stars
around and of course you can't draw zero
dimensional whatever but they took a
picture of it and you know it went
around the world everybody said oh they
proved it proved its existent no first
please define what a black hole is that
term I need to know to know what that
term means before you go look for it out
there or take pictures of it okay okay
so what happened with all these notions
that good old Airy had well the
mathematicians in a sense use it for
like the black hole but that's not the
notion they have they developed a
different notion which probably started
with Descartes Rene Descartes in the
3017 first half of the 17th century and
that's the Cartesian coordinates okay
and so if you ask all the mathematicians
today all these guys are dead but other
disciplines are still around and they
define what a position is which is more
or less what came after the Aristotle's
place and again I think it started with
Descartes I haven't been able to trace
it before that it's the Cartesian
coordinates okay he he came up with that
and so what is position a Euclidean
vector vector is motion okay so we're
talking about position which is a static
concept and they say it's you Killian a
Euclidean vector motion right that
represents the position of a point P in
space in relation to an arbitrary
reference origin oh hey so what are they
talking about well they're talking about
a little arrow that extends from point O
to point P that's a position ah
there's an illustration of that ok here
you'll see it
that's essentially what they're saying
they're saying look you got a point O
and it's tense to a point P okay and in
this case a doesn't matter and so where
are they talking about the tongue in two
three what is that you where you go to
on the x-axis three on the y-axis and
you reach your position your position
with respect to O what are they talking
about they're talking about motion what
they're talking about is you know how to
find a treasure chest they'll give you
instructions or a map that's what
they're talking about they're saying
look you know you want to find the
treasure chest you got to take three
steps to two steps to the right and
three steps
up north from the tree and that's where
the treasure chest is you can dig in and
you'll find it so they're giving you
instructions that's what their same
position its position is a set of
instructions to to find a treasure chest
or whatever you want to locate your
position and from there they developed
also keep this in mind they developed
the notion of the frame of reference
what is a frame of reference well
imagine in space you've got a big steak
you know you hammer it into space I
guess you know put a corner there and
from there you can you know gauge the
motion of all the planets all the stars
everything you want because you put a
steak on the ground you're in space
right this is the notes and they have
and they all it all comes from this
because it's all mathematics but very
little to do with qualitative universe
in which mother nation that nature swims
right okay and so how is that different
from ocean well I don't see any
difference whatsoever because here's
their definition of motions of
mathematicians motion is the change
again motion is changing you can't use a
synonym motion motion is the change in
the position of an object over time so
you need to define time before you can
define motion in mathematical physics
okay that's the first one the second one
is they say it's a change in position so
you have this first arrow it took you to
a then you have the second area to get
appear or whatever right and then that
change in in in location in position in
place that's what they call motion okay
and when you look up teach also a
difference in the state of affairs at
different points in time
sounds a lot like motion so we have
synonym on top of synonym on top of
cinnamon aside from the fact that it's
like you need the word time you need to
find out what time is before you can
define motion because it's part of the
definition and you go to time and you
gotta find the word motion in there so
it's like it's a circular argument you
know time depends on motion motion
depends on time and I got showed last
time around no they're not synonyms
there's a difference time requires
memory and requires two motions you
compare two motions that's why you
require memory okay anyways do we know
what place is well place is just the
hole left behind by an optic when it
leaves and that's more or less what a
black hole is because when the Sun or
the star right
crushes out of existence all matter all
architecture out of existence as they
say you know
crushes it no more architecture no more
structure what's left is a black hole
what is a black hole it's a hole in fact
in space-time but it's like you're
Aristotle's place it's just a hole in
space okay because space is different
than the whole and it's where in this
case a star used to be that started no
longer there the star is gone what's
left behind is the whole but this whole
is zero dimensional these days he I
don't think Aristotle was thinking of
zero dimensional holes but right now we
have zero dimensional holes and that's
what people believe in they believe that
you know through a lot of propaganda a
lot of commercials and spreading of the
word the Catechism people believe that
there are black holes out there some
some kind of body which is not a body a
zero-dimensional body which moves stars
around its you can't see it but they
took pictures of it okay and so yeah
Aristotle started on the wrong foot and
he led everyone that came after on the
wrong foot okay because now we have this
notion of place which I don't think
anybody uses what do we call that in
rational physics we call it position
position is the site occupied by an
object in other words the object itself
that's what position is you don't leave
position behind when you move you don't
leave a hole there as Aristotle thought
no when you move there's no hole left
behind but see Aristotle had to explain
why there's no such thing as nothing he
didn't believe in nothing and so he says
when you move it out something else
occupies its place what occupies that
place I could be water it could be here
he thought of all the four elements
maybe it was even the ether you know the
fifth element there maybe that occupied
the space that the place okay but he
made sure that you understood that that
hole is different than space in other
words that was a hole in space and
that's the same notion these people have
for the black hole anyways with that
we're going to continue along this line
of criticism portal Aristotle
next time around so we'll see that
bye-bye